we're looking at as the name suggests
credit Boeing will give credit cards now
before we get to the exercise and I'm
going to help you interpret and read
some like credit card statements of that
kind of thing if there's one thing if
there is one thing only that you get out
of studying for credit cards okay
it's how to use credit cards properly
which is namely not for credit okay now
you're like it's all credit cards
baloney explain I he's severely put them
up because I do things with them in the
past Dolomites now what I want to have a
look at is we're talking about like
borrowing and interest rates and so on
so if you have a look for example and
awesomely like bank accounts okay
so this is if you put some money in the
bank right and they're going to pay you
interest okay
now does anyone actually know what the
current interest rate is roughly feel
like a bank how much interest you
receive for putting your money in the
bank event
okay so let's find out obviously this
fluctuates it fluctuates through the
year and of course different banks and
different accounts within the bank would
you slightly different well two percent
means two percent one hundred dollars is
not very much two percent of $100,000 is
along so the person has to well it
depends as you see it depends so you can
see they offer you all these different
options
just like we do over the phone this is
really some bells right you have to make
comparisons between things where
sometimes the numerical differences
sometimes there are qualitative
differences like it's really important
to me that I have unlimited data or it's
really important to me that I have only
because of Emma it might be really
important to you that I can get to ATMs
well maybe you don't really care about
get to ATMs I'm not and that's a very
individual thing so if we have a look
for example at just um a savings account
and we pull up okay okay let's go to an
it banks it that's a pretty standard
okay now what was the number Gary two
percent Belushi oh that's okay
alright so you can have a look you know
have a look have a look at read
carefully there's like asterisks and
hash tags everywhere okay
it's like terms of give you to the ply
on everything so what is this it's a
competitive introductory right so for
the first three months they're like yeah
let's get you the door to play 7% that's
attractive at the moment right and then
it will come back to if you if you want
you to find out more if you click again
you'll find out what will actually come
down to after three months okay now this
is important alright just keep this
number in yet that one won't do it right
it's gonna be lower than that in the
long term just remember them now
remember I said to you that credit
borrowing versus let's just go back to
credit and borrowing versus investing
are really two sides of the same coin so
if you are lending money to the bank
they're going to pay you this amount in
return now if you get a credit card then
it's just happening in Reverse so you
ought to expect like interest rates and
all that kind of thing they ought to be
somewhat comparable so you have a look
right and when you see credit cards
there are two kinds are two basic
categories of credit cards there are low
rate and low speed okay now think about
this right if you have borrowing money
you want the right to be low
not high right if you're investing money
you want the right to be high because
that means you get paid lots of things
this right here is an amount you're
gonna have to pay back does that make
sense so being that you've got a choice
between low rate low fee the idea is if
you want a low rate you want to reduce
the Magne have to pay back you're gonna
have a high fee does that make sense you
have to pay for that privilege or
alternatively if you don't want to pay
very much month-to-month then you're
probably gonna have a high rate to
compensate for that does that make sense
alternatively most people who have
credit card like saying your parents for
me they have a free credit card because
it comes along with their with their
bank account which is attached to like a
three hundred thousand dollar debt their
mortgage right so because you're usually
dead to them you're paying them all this
manager said oh really - so let's have a
look
we were thinking two three percent right
get ready to see what's a load rate if
you get a credit card if you get a
credit card how much they're going to
charge you on the money that you are
borrowing from them oh I need to go - do
you see that
hey hold on a second this is the low
rate card right the low rate card
they're gonna charge you
ah only 13.4% that's lovely
oh wait no it's not it's exorbitant
which is why you should never use a
credit card for actual credit for
actually borrowing money now you're
probably thinking yourself well what
else what else can I use it feel all the
explain that in a second before I get to
bed
remember I told you this is the load
right that's a great question if you're
gonna the low fee you notice they didn't
say anything about the right hey don't
tell us you write because they highlight
what's what's good about it which is
enjoy no annual fee right if you spend
so you say oh I better I better learn
more right always going to learn more
okay and when you do that
that is one fee and then there's this
extra bit I'll explain this a bit more
later if you make purchases on your
credit card
generally speaking think about this
right okay you're at the you're at the
checkout you get your card you tap it
right so funds go from there this is a
credit card right this is borrowing
money your money does not pay for that
transaction right um CUA CPAs money or
Visa or iMix
their money pays for your transaction
okay now it doesn't happen instantly
because there are more time usually
times like a week or something so
basically you go to Cole's you've racked
up a bill and then you tell you have not
paid for that transaction CVA is paid
for that transaction
and they're eventually going to say hey
hey all that stuff you bought you owe me
no cuz I pay for that stuff for you
right and if you do not pay them back in
time they will touch it this interest
rate okay if on the other hand what you
do is you go to an ATM and you reach one
cash but now you've got that in your
hand they're going to charge you more
for that because you can do more with
the liquid assets with actually under
any money I spend under a thousand
dollars every year you don't have to
spend anything on fees this is the low
fee card so if you get a lot of rate
card even if you spend nothing on that
card they're gonna charge you a
membership fee like I don't know where
it's $15 a month $30 a month just for
having the car right whereas this is
they're expecting you're going to be
using it and so fine we weren't charging
off